(light ambient music)
- Last year, the day
after Halloween I came up
with the perfect costume,
and then I forgot it, then I
just forgot when Halloween was
this year, and now I don't
have anything to wear.
I'm just not gonna dress up.
- Yeah, this is my first
Halloween doing anything really.
Parents were strict Christians,
so I couldn't really
celebrate the devil's day.
- This is your first
time dressing up ever?
- Yeah.
- Well that changes the game entirely,
we're gonna find something
that's gonna be fun.
Come on, grab as much stuff as you can.
We'll figure something out.
Help me with this rack.
- Oh god.
I'm boom box McGee.
- I'm a robe-guy.
- Where's your leather-back chair?
- I'm a guy who can pull off a cardigan.
- The girl from The Ring.
Or I'm just on TV.
Channel, pick it,
(scoffs) Pick something else.
- I'm the worst guy at a party.
- I'm Indiana Jane.
Or technically I could be
Katniss, Kate-niss. (laughs)
Claire, I like hoagies,
- (mumbling)
- [Man Off Camera] Guys, no.
No.
- It's the PC police.
- It's pretty scary.
- I'm one of those cool girls
who actually likes football.
- This isn't even for a costume,
I just thought it was really dope.
When's the last time you've seen a scroll?
- Not one that nice,
I'll tell you that much.
- Right?
Judge Joe Brown.
- I'm Judge Judy.
- Oh my god, you been
taking up all the air space,
all the ad space.
- You little moron,
do you think I was born yesterday?
- Yeah you were born yesterday obviously,
'cause you're a crackhead.
- Guy with a basketball.
- I guess, or Shaquille O'Neal to scale.
- Come, Nagini.
- Voldemort.
- Yeah, I just don't think I could
keep the voice up all night.
(light techno music)
- What is it?
- Globe Trotter.
- Oh, oh cool.
Look.
- Arthur.
- Yeah!
I'm my uncle Larry.
- I'm the mom from Stranger Things.
(ominous music)
I don't know dude, this is
just a stick of cinnamon.
- A crystal, boy?
- You could be that girl from Harry Potter
who tells the fortune and
she predicts the future
and then no one believes her
and she has the whole prophecy
and no one listens, and then
she was also in Love Actually,
she had a great little
part in Love Actually,
she listened to, um,
shoot, what was her name?
Joni Mitchell, she
listened to Joni Mitchell
and then she dated Alan Rickman,
R-I-P, also in Harry Potter.
Okay, I think I got it, this
is just what I landed on.
- [Man] Yeah, same.
- [Woman] Okay.
- You're me.
- Yeah.
- Looks nice.
- You're uncle Larry.
- Yeah.
- He'll appreciate that.
- He's dead, so.
(music cuts out)
(spooky techno music)